in France this weekend far-right wing
candidate marine lepen lost the
presidential election on the saying she
lost by millions of votes yes yeah and
here's the cool part in France if you
lose by millions of votes that means you
don't get to be President
that's crazy French snuck in the old way
of doing things that doesn't make any
sense no no I've got to get their act
together
lay off the baguettes in Colorado a high
school a lot of people you know mad at
Trump these days and the case in
Colorado a high school teacher has been
put on leave after her class smashed a
president Trump pinata yes yeah when he
heard this Trump was especially furious
that he had been made into something
that brings joy to Mexicans
else is going on this is weird a new
biography of President Obama is coming
out and it claims that before Michelle
he had a fiancee whose parents didn't
think much of Obama's job prospects yeah
actually I think they had a point cuz
now Obama is a 55 year old unemployed
man he's a bum now he's gone lately yeah
get a job man speaking former presidents
former President Bill Clinton is
collaborating on a novel about a u.s.
president who goes missing yeah
Clinton is describing the novel as part
fiction part alibi
my Quentin impression is always him
sneaking holding his shoes and sneaking
out North Korea's upset yeah North Korea
reported that there was a u.s. sponsored
plot launched against Kim jong-un yeah
brought me to see I Aidan CIA agents
tried to sneak up on Kim and give him a
man's haircut government thank you that
this is interesting in Mexico the
world's heaviest man who weighs almost a
thousand pounds is preparing for surgery
yes
the man said after years of being
unhappy with my appearance I'm finally
getting that nose job
thank you very much
nice yeah I feel real good about that
one
in Florida in Florida a ten-year-old
girl pride herself from the jaws of an
eight-foot alligator yeah then the
little girl remembered she lives in
Florida and climbed back in but that's
not the point
emma watson is exciting emma watson has
won MTV's first-ever non-gender acting
award non gender gender gender-neutral
that's right she won the coveted Conan
and
[Applause]
you